all right so let's go to the performance
category uh we'll start with a protein
because that's of course foundational
for building muscle
um you guys use a beef protein and i've
i've never used the beef protein in my
life this is this is the stuff here you
know this this is a container um
why beef like why not whey why not casey
and why not fermented uh vegetables like
um i had john uh jacques on a couple
weeks ago why not any of those things
like why is zepro like
vegetable protein
um i know it's a vegan product but i
think he said that it's uh almost 100
absorbable was his big pitch but it's
also quite expensive it's over a hundred
bucks a container
look at it and you also have to consider
food intolerances autoimmune conditions
most vegan proteins are using grains
uh they're also going to be blending
things like pea protein which is often
times gmo unless you're sourcing it
properly and the thing when it comes
down to vegetable-based proteins the
reason you're gonna find a vegan protein
with several forms of protein so
cranberry protein hemp protein pumpkin
seed protein and they'll blend that in a
formula is because there is no true
potent
you know plant or vegetable based source
of all of those amino acids that you
need to get those building blocks of
muscle that you're talking about and yes
i'm sure that there are vegans and
vegetarians that are doing it properly
and if you are amazing but for the most
part you're lacking and leucine you're
lacking in methionine uh there's zinc
carnosine carnosine and carnitine and
creatine are pretty much non-existent in
your vegetable-based proteins so yeah
the reason we went with that we should
get moff's comment up while you're
talking can you do that rich which one i
can't see
845 he did yeah there you go that one
there we go so let's just let moth take
it away your your bio availability sure
you could probably reach higher levels
so in the literature whey is going to
give you a hundred percent
bioavailability so whey is king in the
literature and it's undeniable that
majority of research is done using whey
however a lot of us are intolerant to
dairy and i'm not talking about lactose
intolerance you know if you eat some ice
cream and you [ __ ] yourself an hour
later you're lactose intolerant yeah
you're talking about farting like crazy
i'm talking about food intolerances
though that are a little bit more
insidious and you typically don't see
symptoms until 48 hours later and it's
you're going to be hard-pressed to
connect the whey protein shake that you
had two days ago to the mucous
production and eczema that you have on
your skin but the reality is there's a
massive connection there so the reason
we went with something really
hypoallergenic
like the beef protein is it's tolerated
in everyone except vegans and um you're
getting a hypoallergenic product with a
98 bioavailability so pretty damn close
to what you're getting with whey however
none of the inflammatory processes
definitely able to be tolerated by more
people and this is a product that
actually comes out of sweden this
specific raw material is really
interesting and it does have a lot of
properties similar to bone broth so if
you love what bone broth gives to you
some of those collagen forming amino
acids like proline and glycine you're
getting a similar profile here
yeah and
like um someone said whey protein
isolate who was it
look like whey is
i take away i take beef i sort of rotate
it i actually learned one of my other
mentors his name is preston green he's
the head strength coach of the florida
gators
he recommends for like optimal
performance and optimal health you
should be rotating your protein sources
so whey protein even if you can tolerate
it's a good idea to like sub in a beef
protein once in a while i do one way one
beef and i just rotate that every single
day um
and as melissa mentioned it's bone broth
like protein
so it's actually 70
collagen forming amino acids in this
protein powder and we all hear about
collagen for your like skin your joints
um it helps heal your gut there's some
evidence on that
the nice thing about this one too is
it's completely heat like you can
actually put this in your coffee in the
morning if you want like a quick
breakfast too and please do it's so good
um actually
that's what i've been doing since
since you mentioned jordan to put the
collagen in my coffee in the morning
because there's also a collagen product
which we may add to the lineup in the
future but i've been testing yours um
you know as it stands it makes the
coffee taste amazing i was like you know
i'm kind of looking off the side because
i got the collagen and i got the beef
protein i'm like [ __ ] it i'll just mix
them all in together yeah it actually
makes your coffee taste like a mocha
yeah yeah because it's a chocolate
flavored beef protein like you taste no
beef whatsoever it tastes really good
yeah it's it's like it's good it's
better to eat breakfast but if you're in
a rush like it's there's nothing better
you get 21 grams of protein with this
then you got the collagen it's another
10. it doesn't it doesn't mix very well
like you really have to mix it for a
while either that or just put it in a
blender blender that's it's one downside
um
like it is beef you would have no idea
if i did a taste test for you but it's
not
it's not as easily as mixable as like a
whey protein isolate yeah
you